What's up, D.C.!
There's a lot of anti-immigrant
sentiment right now.
People need to know
that we love America.
We come here for a reason,
and we contribute to America
in many ways, right?
Some immigrants actually voted for Trump
because they wanted fewer taxes,
but they ended up with fewer relatives.
And I went down to the protest, yeah!
It's so much fun.
Suddenly, the riot police came out.
But the white dudes did not care!
They're just, "Out of my way, copper.
Here I come. It's my right."
I'm in the back.
I'm like, "Calm down, white guy!"
"You're gonna get us in trouble!"
Kids are running the world now.
You know how I know?
'Cause when I was a kid,
I used to have to play
with the kids of my parents' friends.
Now I have to play with the parents
of my kids' friends.
Now, in America, you got to put
your kid in a car seat...
till they're 35 years old,
with a helmet on,
and a video player, just--
This is a learning experience,
ladies and gentlemen.
Immigrants giving to the culture.